and thanks for joining us tonight i'm
denise valdez an effort to control
rising rent costs struck down in north
las vegas the culinary union pushing for
a new initiative to curb costs to go to
the vote in november but the city says
the plan didn't have the right support
to move forward sasha loftis was there
tonight and she joins us with how this
all unfolded denise those pushing for
this initiative say it's imperative to
keep people in their homes but city
officials say the rules are black and
white and since it didn't have enough
signatures it won't be considered at the
ballot box this november
i see people struggling amroka says
everyone around her is affected by
rising rent costs i see people getting
almost evicted for this people's being
unfair roca tells us the prices where
she lives in north las vegas have
skyrocketed in the last few years and
her family isn't sure how to handle it i
will be back up here because i am
passionate this is the topic that turned
heated at wednesday's north las vegas
city council meeting as roca and dozens
of others showed up to push for a new
initiative we urge you not to support
these corporate landlords who benefit
from these exorbitant rents the culinary
union submitted thousands of signatures
to neighborhood stability in june all to
get the ordinance which would prevent
rent from exceeding the cost of living
on the november ballot that is the long
and the short of it
they simply did not meet the required
threshold but city officials say they
didn't have enough supporters based on a
total number of voters in the june
primary to move forward and sided with
the city clerk to name the effort
insufficient i'd like to make a motion
to approve the city clerk's certificate
regardless many say they want those on
council to reconsider as they continue
their effort to fight for change
affordable rent for everybody that's all
we want
after tonight's meeting the culinary
released a statement saying they will
file a lawsuit in state district court
against the city of north las vegas to
challenge its decision to deem this
position insufficient denise